Transcriber: Rama Ali
المدقّق: Yasmeen Elsayed
(موسيقى)
السلام عليكم، كيف الحال؟
أنا اسمي ماريا
اليوم سأكلمكم عن شيء مهم بالنسبة لنا،
ومتعب بالنسبة  للأمهات والأباء
وهي إدمان الشاشات.
حسناً، لكل شيء إيجابيات وسلبيات
فأجهزة الموبايل تسمح لنا
بالتواصل مع أي شخص وفي أي مكان
تريده وبضغطة زر
وفيه ألعاب مسلية  وتعليمية بنفس الوقت.
وتنمي مهارة الإبداع عند الطفل.
لكن دعوني أسألكم سؤال، هل يتذكر أحد منكم
آخر عشر فيديوهات شاهدها؟
لا، هذا ما يحصل عندما تدخل
أفكار غير مفيدة إلى عقلك
وخصوصًا عندما تكون فيديوهات قصيرة
مثل ال “شورتس” أو ال “ريلز“.
أود أن أخبركم عن
سلبيات أجهزة الموبايل.
أول شيء، أنها تهدر الوقت
الأمر الذي يؤثر على
التحصيل الدراسي والمذاكرة،
ويسبب إدمان،
ويقلل من التركيز.
دعوني أخبركم عن تجربتي مع أجهزة الموبايل.
كل أصدقائي يملكون أجهزة موبايل عدا أنا
طلبت من والدي ووالدتي لكنهم رفضوا
وأعطوني فرصة لأكتشف نفسي.
وفعلاً بدأت أحب القراءة شيئًا فشيئًا،
مع أني كنت أظن أنها مملة للغاية،
إلا أنني أحببتها بعد ذلك
وعلى فكرة، عالم القراءة
مثل عالم أجهزة الموبايل بالضبط
من المفروض أن نكون حذرين حول ما نقرأ
وتعلمت الخياطة أو ما زلت أتعلم بالأحرى.
و أنتم أيضاً، أعطوا فرصة لأبنائكم
لاكتشاف أنفسهم.
لا تتركوا أجهزة الموبايل بيد أبنائكم
و إن لم تسطيعوا منعها بشكل كامل
فقللوا من وقت استخدامها ما أمكن
العالم خارج الشاشات واسع جداً،
يستحق أن تريه لإبنك.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)
(موسيقى).